¿Podrían los Estados Unidos estar
deseando que Rusia invada Ucrania?
Este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a
Cambly una plataforma para practicar
inglés de forma individual con
tutores nativos especializados.
Moscú se ha enrocado. Tropas, tanques,
misiles y buques de guerra procedentes
de todos los distritos militares del país han
sido desplegados junto a la frontera de Ucrania.
Todo parece listo para una gran ofensiva.
¿El motivo? Supuestamente contrarrestar
el creciente peso de la OTAN en la región.
Pero…. Y si el resultado de esta operación fuera
exactamente el contrario al pretendido por Moscú.
Queridos amigos y amigas, estoy completamente
seguro de que todos habéis escuchado hablar
mucho sobre el conflicto entre Rusia,
Ucrania, Estados Unidos y la Unión Europea.
Sin embargo, puede que no os hayáis hecho una
pregunta fundamental: ¿Podrían los Estados
Unidos estar deseando que finalmente se
produjera la invasión Rusia de Ucrania?
No, os aseguro que no se nos ha ido la cabeza.
En este vídeo vamos a echar un vistazo a los 4 grandes motivos
por los que para Rusia la invasión de
Ucrania podría ser un tremendo error. La gran
trampa a la que se enfrenta Vladimir Putin.
Atentos.
[Pero, un momento. Antes de continuar os quiero
hablar de Cambly [PRON. KÊMBLI], una plataforma
para practicar y mejorar tu inglés. Gracias a ella vamos a poder terminar
de una vez por todas con la mayor pesadilla
del mundo hispano: el dominio del inglés.
Desde tu casa o desde el lugar que
quieras y con tan solo un ordenador,
podrás conectarte con uno de los miles
de tutores nativos que hay en Cambly.
Estoy seguro de que podrás encontrar
uno que se ajuste a tus necesidades.
¿Qué quieres mejorar tu inglés para los negocios?
Pues tendrás tutores expertos en este tema.
¿Qué quieres ir a Londres, a Singapur o
a Chicago, por ejemplo, y lo necesitas
para viajar? Pues también encontrarás
tutores nativos que te ayudaran con ello.
Necesites el inglés para lo que lo necesites,
con Cambly tendrás a tu disposición una
plataforma de clases individuales para
ayudarte. Interesante, ¿no os parece?.
Pues atentos porque para conseguir tus
objetivos con el inglés, ahora y hasta
el 17 de febrero de 2022, Cambly te regala un
cupón con un 50% de descuento en cualquier plan
anual. Es decir, ¡podrás aprender inglés
todo el año y 6 meses te saldrán gratis!
Y eso no es todo, además, ahora que se acerca San
Valentín también podrás regalarle
un mes gratis a quien tú quieras.
Ah, ¡importante! Todos los que os registréis
podréis probar el servicio durante 10 minutos
de forma completamente gratuita y sin necesidad
de introducir ninguna tarjeta de crédito. Vamos,
sin ningún compromiso. ¡Y ojo porque esto sí que
es para siempre! Veas cuando veas este vídeo.
De verdad, si queréis mejorar con el inglés,
no dejéis pasar esta ofertaza e introducid el
código LOVEVP en Cambly, o LOVEVPKIDS en Cambly
Kids al seleccionar un plan para conseguirla.
Ya no tenéis excusas para no aprender inglés.]
Dicho esto, en un próximo vídeo os contaremos
las bazas con las que cuenta Rusia,
así que no te olvides suscribirte a
VisualPolitik y darle a la campanita.
Y ahora sí, arranquemos.
(1. EL
AVISPERO UCRANIANO)
Queridos amigos, la República de Ucrania
no es precisamente un país pequeño. Con
más de 600 mil kilómetros cuadrados
y unos 40 millones de habitantes,
una invasión rusa a gran escala
sería tremendamente costosa.
Y no me refiero solo al coste de la
invasión sino sobre todo a la ocupación.
Me explico. Todo apunta a que el ejército
ucraniano no tendría mucho que hacer contra
las tropas rusas. Por número de efectivos,
por arsenal o por experiencia en combate,
los más de 120 mil soldados con los que
el Kremlin ha rodeado Ucrania parecen
tenerlo todo para cumplir la misión con éxito.
C1("Tienes un ejército terrestre
ucraniano que se ha vuelto mucho mejor,
mucho más capaz. "Pero los rusos serían
dueños del aire y el mar". Philip Breedlove,
General retirado de la fuerza
aérea de Estados Unidos)
Claro que, un momento, porque
la diferencia de fuerzas fue
siempre mucho mayor en Afganistán
y a pesar de ello tanto la Unión
Soviética como los propios Estados Unidos
se enfrentaron a una guerra interminable.
Pues bien, algo así podría ocurrir en Ucrania.
(Primero la invasión podría conllevar un
importante desgaste y muchas
bajas para las tropas rusas.
No olvidemos que bajo los gobiernos
de Poroshenko y Zelensky, el ejército
ucrania ha mejorado considerablemente;
más de 400 mil personas han adquirido
experiencia de combate y los Estados
Unidos y el resto de países de la OTAN
les han suministrado una gran cantidad
de misiles antitanques y antiaéreos.
En esta línea el 1 de enero entró en vigor
la Ley de Resistencia Nacional que tiene el
objetivo de movilizar a 120 mil reservistas,
muchos de ellos con experiencia de combate,
para apoyar a los más de 200 mil efectivos con los
que cuenta a día de hoy el ejercito ucraniano.)
Por supuesto, sobra decir que cualquier fracaso en
el frente podría ser desastroso para
el régimen político de Vladimir Putin.
Segundo, la ocupación posterior a la invasión
podría agotar tanto las arcas como las propias
fuerzas del ejército ruso. Porque seamos
claros, cualquier intento de ocupar el
país conllevaría una fuerte resistencia
y mucha actividad de grupos insurgentes.
C2 ("Todo el mundo se compra armas para luchar
contra los rusos. Tenemos muchos clubes a los que
la gente va a diario a entrenarse”. Miroslav
Gai, excombatiente en el frente del Donbass)
Movimientos que, además, no lo dudéis
ni un segundo, serían financiados,
entrenados y apoyados por la propia OTAN.
El objetivo sería siempre maximizar el
coste económico, militar y político
que una invasión tendría para Rusia.
(EE. UU. Considera respaldar la insurgencia
si Rusia invade Ucrania. NYTimes)
C3 ("La triste realidad es que Rusia puede tomar
tanto de Ucrania como quiera, pero no puede
aguantarla" Melinda Haring, Subdirectora
del Atlantic Council's Eurasia Center)
Y todo ello, insisto, dando por
hecho que durante la invasión
los rusos no sufrieran ninguna complicación.
Evidentemente cuanto mayor fuera el objetivo
de la invasión mayor serían los riesgos.
Claro que la posibilidad de
meterse en todo un avispero
es tan solo uno de los riesgos que
esta operación plantea para Rusia.
Atentos.
S (2. ¿POR QUÉ DESATAR UNA
CARRERA QUE NO PUEDES GANAR?)
Prestad mucha atención a estas palabras de Jens Stoltenberg,
el mismísimo Secretario General de la OTAN.
C4("Si la intención de Rusia era
conseguir menos OTAN cerca de su frontera,
ha conseguido exactamente lo contrario. Y
si vuelven a usar la fuerza contra Ucrania,
conseguirán aún más OTAN en sus fronteras. Jens
Stoltenberg, Secretario General de la OTAN)
Hasta ahora la excusa que ha utilizado una y
otra vez el Kremlin para amenazar la soberanía
de Ucrania ha sido la de querer frenar la
expansión de la OTAN en el frente oriental.
Pues bien, el resultado de una invasión puede
ser exactamente el contrario por 3 motivos.
Primero, la invasión de Ucrania puede
provocar que al menos dos nuevos países,
Suecia y Finlandia, para garantizar su
seguridad terminen uniéndose al Tratado
del Atlántico Norte para garantizar su seguridad.
Cómo mínimo la cooperación de estos dos países
con la OTAN se vería reforzada, que, por
cierto, es precisamente lo que han venido
haciendo durante los últimos años a medida
que hemos visto a una Rusia más agresiva.
C5 (“Suecia y Finlandia han incrementado
la cooperación bilateral con Estados
Unidos [..] Suecia se dio cuenta de la
amenaza de Moscú el Viernes Santo de 2013,
cuando aviones militares rusos simularon
una operación de bombardeo a gran escala
sobrevolando Estocolmo”. William
Alberque, director de Estrategia,
Tecnología y Control de Armamento del
International Institute for Strategic Studies.)
En segundo lugar, una operación militar en
Ucrania volvería a cohesionar a la mayoría
de los integrantes de la OTAN, especialmente a
los países del centro y del este de Europa que
se abrazarían sin dudarlo a Washington
y al proyecto de seguridad atlántica.
Sería por así decirlo la forma de volver a
poner en forma la Alianza. Queridos amigos,
podemos decir que Putin sería a la
OTAN lo que las espinacas son a Popeye.
Y en tercer lugar, quizás la cuestión más
importante de todas. La invasión de Ucrania
muy probablemente terminaría desatando una enorme
carrera armamentística en el nuevo telón de
acero que se está formando en el este de Europa.
Una carrera que Rusia no puede ganar. Los
países europeos tienen economías mucho más
ricas y acceso a tecnología más avanzada.
Así que si hace 30 años la Unión Soviética
cayó exhausta tras una enorme carrera militar
con Estados Unidos, ahora esa misma
situación se puede volver a reproducir.
De momento, países como Polonia, Estonia
o Suecia ya han anunciado presupuestos
militares récords para reconstruir y
mejorar sus fuerzas armadas. Con una
invasión podrías esperar prácticamente lo mismo
de la inmensa mayor parte de países de Europa.
(Suecia aumentará su gasto en defensa
en un 40% ante el temor a Rusia.Forbes)
(Polonia planea reforzar el ejército en
medio de las amenazas de Bielorrusia y Rusia
El ejército polaco ha anunciado planes para
duplicar con creces su número de tropas. DW)
(El presupuesto de defensa estonio
para 2022 será el más grande de la
historia. Shephard Media)
Y son tan solo 3 ejemplos.
Sumadle a todo esto un mayor
despliegue de tropas y equipos
de países como Estados Unidos o Reino Unido.
En otras palabras, Putin puede lograr lo que
Washington no ha conseguido en un montón de años:
que los presupuestos militares
de Europa superen el 2% del PIB.
Es decir, que si el propósito
de Putin era frenar a la OTAN
el resultado de una invasión
sería exactamente el contrario.
Y, ¿Sabéis qué? No hemos hecho más
que empezar. Aquí no terminan ni
mucho menos las pérdidas potenciales para Rusia.
Atentos.
(3. LA GRAN BAZA RUSA QUE PUEDE DESAPARECER)
¡Con el gas hemos topado!
Amigos, Durante la Guerra Fría, la Unión
Soviética no dejó de vender gas a Europa,
incluyendo a la Europa Occidental. La venta de gas
ha sido para Rusia una importante fuente
de divisas durante las últimas décadas.
(Quizás precisamente por esa condición de
proveedor confiable y barato los países
europeos no han tenido mucho inconveniente en
incrementar su dependencia del gas ruso hasta
niveles récords. Aproximadamente un tercio de todo
el gas que se consume en Europa procede de Rusia.)
Sin embargo, ahora eso podría empezar a cambiar.
Las reducciones en el suministro y
el uso del gas con fines políticos
podrían significar el fin de la
complacencia europea. Sobre todo
si tras una invasión rusa de Ucrania se
recrudece la tensión entre las dos partes.
Y ojo porque este ha sido un viejo anhelo
de Estado Unidos que no quiere ni por
asomo que sus aliados de la OTAN
sean rehenes energéticos de Moscú.
[Además, no lo olvidéis, Estados Unidos aspira
a convertirse en un importante exportador de Gas
Natural Licuado. Gas que en parte podría
suplir las importaciones desde Rusia]
C6 ("Estamos colaborando con gobiernos y
operadores del mercado en el suministro
de volúmenes adicionales de gas natural
a Europa desde diversas fuentes en todo
el mundo" Declaración conjunta de
Joe Biden y Ursula von der Leyen.)
De esta forma, la consecuencia automática
de una invasión podría ser la cancelación
del Nord Stream 2 y la búsqueda
urgente de fuentes alternativas.
Fuentes quizás más caras pero mucho
mejores en términos de seguridad.
En esta misma línea, por ejemplo, países
como Polonia o Estonia ya han confirmado
que quieren construir nuevas centrales nucleares.
Así que, a medio plazo si las economías
europeas se toman en serio lo de buscar
alternativas al gas procedente de Rusia,
incluso aunque fuera parcialmente,
el golpe para la economía rusa sería
simple y llanamente devastador.
Tened en cuenta que el petróleo y el
gas suponen dos tercios de todas las
exportaciones rusas y aproximadamente
la mitad del presupuesto federal.
En esa situación, Rusia no tendría
más remedio que realizar enormes
inversiones para venderle gas
a precio de saldo a los chinos.
Es decir, que la invasión podría
terminar erosionando una de las
grandes bazas políticas - y económicas -
que hoy por hoy tiene Rusia. En 10 años
la situación energética de Europa podría ser
muy pero que muy diferente a la de hoy en día.
Y, por cierto, hablando de impacto
económico. Ojo con el cuarto gran
motivo por el que la invasión de
Ucrania podría ser un colosal error.
SANCIONES, SANCIONES Y MÁS SANCIONES)
En esta ocasión el juego diplomático
está desarrollándose básicamente así:
Moscú amenaza con invadir Ucrania, y entonces la
respuesta de Washington y el resto de capitales
europeas pasa por amenazar con más y más
sanciones económicas. Y vuelta a empezar.
Lo que, por otra parte, no resulta nada nuevo.
(Desde que Rusia se anexionó Crimea la
comunidad internacional ha castigado al
país de Vladimir Putin con un montón de sanciones.
Fundamentalmente de 3 tipos:
sanciones financieras,
sanciones contra oligarcas cercanos al Kremlin y
algunas restricciones a la compra de tecnología.
Esta es una estrategia que puso en
marcha Barack Obama y que luego ha
sido ampliada por Donald Trump y Joe Biden.)
Existe cierto debate sobre la
efectividad de las sanciones
con las que hasta ahora se ha castigado a Rusia.
Sin embargo, lo cierto es que desde que
se pusieron en marcha las sanciones la
economía rusa va de mal en peor. Desde el 2014
apenas ha crecido a una media del 0,3% anual.
Y sí, ya sé lo que muchos estaréis pensando.
Hombre Enrique, es que este tiempo coincidió con
el hundimiento del precio del petróleo. Pues sí,
pero no se trata sólo del crecimiento económico.
(Desde que se aprobaron las sanciones contra la
economía rusa la entrada de inversión extranjera
directa se desplomó a menos de la mitad. Para que
os hagáis una idea, esto supone que entre el 2014
y el 2019, por ejemplo, Rusia perdió unos 169 mil
millones de dólares en inversiones productivas.
Y eso no es todo. Si a esto le sumamos que los
mercados de capitales se cerraron en gran medida,
tanto para el gobierno como sobre todo
para las empresas rusas, el resultado
es que tanto los niveles de inversión como
de productividad han ido de mal en peor.
Entre otras cosas esto es lo que
explica porque durante estos años
el ingreso disponible de los rusos
se ha desplomado más de un 10% y
por qué la tasa de cambio del rublo
con el dólar cayó más de un 50%.)
Pero, ¿Queréis un ejemplo
concreto? Pues fijaos. Indonesia,
Argelia y Egripto acaban de renunciar
a comprar el Sukhoi SU-35S, una de las
joyas de la aviación militar rusa y uno de los
elementos clave del catálogo militar del país.
Pero, la pregunta es, ¿Por qué
están cancelando los pedidos?
Pues, precisamente, porque por culpa de las
sanciones Rusia no puede importar componentes
vitales para la aviónica y el radar de este avión,
lo que afecta considerablemente a sus capacidades.
Pese a todo, las sanciones que se han establecido
hasta el momento han sido más bien modestas.
Lo que ahora podría cambiar.
El paquete de sanciones que estarían
barajando Estados Unidos y la Unión
Europea si Rusia finalmente invade
Ucrania va muchísimo más allá.
Por ejemplo, se habla de grandes controles
de exportación, de sacar a los bancos rusos
del sistema internacional de comunicación
bancaria - el sistema Swift -, de cortar
por completo la financiación a los
bancos y al gobierno ruso o incluso,
entre muchas otras, de medidas
tan agresivas como esta:
N5 (Biden amenaza con prohibir
el dólar a los bancos rusos
Estados Unidos dijo que podría
impedir que las instituciones
financieras rusas comerciaran en
dólares si Moscú invade Ucrania.)
Es decir, se trataría no solo de dañar la economía
rusa sino sobre todo de impedir su desarrollo.
Y, esto es importante, porque,
amigos, amigas, no nos engañemos:
a largo plazo un país con menos recursos es
un país condenado a ser mucho menos poderoso.
En Washington lo saben y esta puede ser
la oportunidad perfecta para hacerlo.
C8("Sería un desastre, una pesadilla
para el mercado financiero interno".
Sergey Aleksashenko, ex vicepresidente
primero del Banco Central de Rusia)
De momento, las empresas internacionales que
se estaban planteando invertir en Rusia han
congelado o cancelados estos proyectos, la bolsa
de Moscú ha caído con fuerza y la prima de riesgo
Son, por así decirlo, las primeras consecuencias
de la arriesgada apuesta que ha hecho Moscú.
C7 (“Putin se ha excedido en su
juego con Ucrania”. Robert Gates,
Ex Secretario de Defensa de Estados Unidos)
Ahora bien, ¿Quiere decir todo esto que no
habrá invasión? Para nada. La estrategia
diplomática seguida por Estados Unidos y
la OTAN en cierto modo han acorralado a
Putin, que solo va a tener 3 opciones:
Retirarse humillado.
Pactar un acuerdo que pueda vender pero sin sacar
nada destacada y haciendo a su
vez concesiones a Occidente.
O invadir Ucrania. Posiblemente mediante una
invasión parcial, tal y como os hemos contado
en Las Claves de la Semana, el boletín que
recibís todos los que nos apoyáis en Patreon.
En este caso, puede que las consecuencias fueran
graduales en función de cómo de grande fuera
la invasión. Ese está siendo seguramente
el cálculo que están haciendo en Moscú.
Incluso la acción rusa podría limitarse
a reconocer la independencia de los
territorios controlados por las
fuerzas prorrusas en el Donbass.
Al fin y al cabo, si Putín hubiera
querido invadir Ucrania lo normal
es que ya lo hubiera hecho. Las tropas
rusas llevan estacionadas meses en el
frente. No tiene sentido esperar a que
sus adversarios refuercen sus defensas.
Y ojo, porque esta es, por ejemplo, la idea
que defiende el propio gobierno ucraniano,
que una y otra vez afirma que
ellos no ven por ningún lado
un riesgo real de que Rusia lleve a
cabo una gran invasión en el país.
Sea como sea, todo parece indicar que en
esta ocasión Washington está dispuesto a
jugar fuerte. Putin, un líder acostumbrado
a realizar apuestas arriesgadas podría haber
sobreestimado esta vez sus posibilidades
de victoria en todo este embrollo.
Ahora el resultado es que haga lo que haga Moscú,
en casi todos los escenarios el ganador más
probable es precisamente Estados Unidos. Un país
que no tiene nada que perder y sí mucho que ganar
en toda esta historia. Esta, amigos, puede ser la
gran trampa a la que se enfrenta Vladimir Putin.
Pero dicho esto turno para ti: ¿Creés
que Putin ha sobreestimado sus fuerzas
o crees que al final se saldrá con la
suya? ¿Qué creés que puede ganar Rusia
invadiendo Ucrania? ¿Cuál tendría
que ser la respuesta de la OTAN?
Déjanos por aquí tus opiniones y
abramos debate. Y ahora si este
vídeo te ha resultado interesante no olvides
darle a like y suscribirte a VisualPolitik.
Muchas gracias por estar ahí,
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.